it's been a couple of weeks now since
you've
taken over the post um for those who
don't know
obviously you've been involved in local
politics for a long time tell us a
little bit about your background
and why you feel you are the right
person to run the state democratic party
thank you well i have over 27
years managing multi-billion dollar
projects
infrastructure projects for engineering
firms so my last project was a light
rail transit system
which was 7.2 billion dollars and that
includes you know managing resources
personnel
contractors consultants so i have that
kind of background professional
experience to bring to the job
okay um correlations between
uh that kind of job and the democratic
party
are what okay so you know as
as you know a lot of money goes through
the state party and
especially during the time of the
coordinated campaign
a lot of the money goes to the party we
also have a lot of
contracts with consultants we have to
hire staff
manage that personnel and manage our
resources allocate the resources
effectively
so that we're making sure that we're
doing the job right and we're making
sure that we have the resources to elect
democrats
it was uh interesting to watch the race
as it developed and as
it took hold there's the quote
establishment democrats and and
i it seems like there's a divide i think
there seems to be an agreement that
there's a divide i guess the question is
moving forward is there a desire by you
to keep the party together moving
forward to try and
bridge both edges of the same
dnc absolutely well i've actually been
involved here
since 2016 i've been up was on both
central committees and then in 2017
i ran for executive board for the clark
county democratic party
so i've actually been doing the work for
quite a while now here in nevada
i'm working with all wings or factions
how you know whatever you want to call
it of the democratic party
so um this isn't something new
there's always been you know this a
little bit of a divide between
you know what direction each faction
wants to take the party but at the end
of the day we're all democrats and we
will
unify and we will elect democrats um
that's what we're here for
so we know that no progress
is possible without electing democrats
so progressives are very
invested in making sure that happens and
we're also invested in bringing everyone
together to make sure that we
are ready in 2022 uh because to us
it's an absolute necessity that we
re-elect governor sislek
and senator cortez masto and we have a
senate majority
we're not going to give that up we're
not going absolutely not going to give
that up
so we are here to do the work and i
think once everybody sees that we're
doing the work
to keep the democratic party not only
functioning but also expanding and
growing the democratic party to include
all different ideologies and also making
sure that we're doing the outreach and
the community engagement and bypass
bipod communities as well so we're going
to be bringing people
into the party which is always a good
thing for us here in nevada
so you're not concerned about again the
quote establishment democrat
kind of working around your own uh
your own team well i would highly
caution against that because
the state democratic party is the only
effective structure for electing
democrats and for doing that kind of
work
especially working with the coordinated
campaign um
we're very closely aligned with the dnc
right now
we are you know doing the work already
you know we're open for business and so
it's not to the benefit of our
democratic candidates
for there to be any kind of a divide or
for any kind of a workaround
um because it puts them at risk and it
puts our elections at risk
so it's very very important that we are
all working together we're all on the
same page
uh and i understand you know the little
bit of concern there always is when
there's transition or new leadership
but i'm here to elect democrats that's
my primary job
how much turnover has there been at the
state
democratic party since you took over
to my knowledge there was probably four
staffers that quit
other than that i haven't seen any huge
turnaround i haven't seen any
resignations
we still have almost 600 people on our
state central committee no one's
resigned from that
so as far as i'm concerned we're all
still here and we're all doing the work
okay uh let's um look ahead a little bit
there's some discussion up at the
legislative session about uh
changes to the elections we all
acknowledge what happened because of the
coronavirus in the last general election
and the primaries the caucus and so
forth
um what would you like to see from a
democratic standpoint moving forward and
what kind of
are you looking ahead already to having
a caucus how that'll be
given the changes for the the next
election
i expect that we will move to a primary
system
i think the caucuses disenfranchised a
lot of voters
although they were helpful in rural
areas to bring people together
we were finding that you know a lot of
people found it difficult to participate
on caucus day
or were really comfortable participating
in that kind of a format
even with the early voting um you know
we saw that that
a lot of people early voted and stood in
line for
hours to cast their ballot you know in
and
so that tells us that people don't
really like the caucus system
um we've got to move to a primary system
here in nevada
and there is a bill going through the
legislative legislative
uh process right now
and i expect that it will pass
as i recall though the the caucus
framework certainly
uh was more beneficial to the more
progressive
end of the democratic party would
going away from that compromise the
ability of that
element of the democrats to have that
voice to have that
uh impact on the on the election
not at all i think actually it will turn
out more voters which is always good for
democrats
i mean when you're talking about
non-voters nonpartisans
they don't really like to engage in a
caucus system
they're not comfortable with it so we've
got
to do a better job of opening up the
process
and make sure that everyone has the
opportunity to vote
and by doing primaries running them like
7 a.m to 7 p.m over multiple days
more people are going to vote it's just
that simple so
for us for democrats that's always good
uh higher turnout is good for us and and
i'm looking forward to moving to that
primary process
you were mentioning uh now that you're
running the state
uh democratic party uh getting all
sides involved reaching out and so forth
to both ends of the political party all
the issues and et cetera et cetera
do you think the establishment that was
in place before
was not taking those into consideration
when they were setting up platforms and
they were
picking candidates when they were
fundraising whatever advocates whatever
the case may be
were there aspects of
what was happening on the ground that
was missing maybe in the political in
the democratic party
well what i've seen in the past is that
we've had a lot of successes
um but it's time to build on those
successes and start moving
into some more innovative solutions some
more customizable solutions in different
counties i've had meetings with rural
chairs and talk about their needs
and those areas and and we're mapping
out statewide election strategies
from the bottom up uh so i don't think
it's a matter of
of this the so-called divide i think
it's a matter of
opening up more opportunities and more
opportunities for people to engage for
them to be involved
we need to be out doing the work year
round not just at election time if we're
going to engage people
when i hear people talking when i'm out
in the community
they talk about the fact that yes we we
turned out to vote against trump in the
last election
but we feel like our needs aren't being
met we feel like we're not being
represented or
our voices aren't being heard so we have
to do a better job
of engaging on the ground with all of
our bipart communities with everyone in
nevada
to make sure that we're listening that
we're addressing those concerns and
those issues
and that we're working hard to bring
more people into the party
by giving them the opportunity to be
part of the process
um and that they feel like we are
invested in those communities and then
they in turn
are more likely to turn out when we need
them to vote
uh so we're not going to just pay lip
service at election time
we're going to be on the ground engaging
year round and i think that's going to
be the key
in building on the past successes and
looking to the future
um and being able to expand and grow the
democratic party because
we have to be able to do that we can't
just exist in a bubble
i think a lot of times um in the past as
democrats we tended to sort of
um isolate ourselves and just expect
you know that certain communities of
certain constituencies were going to
automatically vote democrat
and we found that that's not true um
i've also been concerned about the
narrowing margins
in our in our last victories i mean
we've seen that we've had some successes
we've had some really great successes in
the past uh but in order to continue
those successes
we've got to stop that trend where
nonpartisan registration numbers
continue to grow at a fast pace
and and democratic party and even
republican party registration has gone
down
so it's it's on us to make sure that we
start to build those numbers back up
again it's on us to do the work and make
sure that communities feel that we are
representing them
so that's the kind of work that we're
going to continue
so by extension then is it
fair to say that maybe i'm just going to
use the term read machine
is the read machine antiquated versus
say
maybe yourself and others whether it's a
more progressive
a dsa point of view a more
a different take or a different point of
view on the democratic party
is the read machine antiquated
i just think that we're looking to build
on those past successes
we recognize all the hard work and all
the success
of everyone you know of the democratic
party
in the past several years i mean we know
that there have been some huge
democratic victories
i mean we have a democratic governor for
like the first time in 20 years
um you know we have a senate majority in
d.c now
so we've got to hold on to that and by
building on the past successes i think
that we can continue
those successes and improve on them um
and that's all we're looking to do is
build on the past successes
and make sure that we're starting to
talk about new ideas
i mean this pandemic has shown us that
we have to start thinking outside the
box a lot more
we have to think about ways to engage
people um
not just you know door knocking which
will continue to be
important phone banks which will
continue to be important but we've got
to look at new technologies new ideas
for engaging people
year round if we're going to expand on
those successes
so finally what's one big outside the
box
thing that you want to do right away
well we're moving to to reorganize our
get out of the boat structure
so we're going to be rolling out an
assembly captain program and we're doing
a pilot program
at the red rock democratic club in the
next couple of months so we're
restructuring our get out the boat
um to make it more manageable um
and to make it more personal we're going
to be doing a lot of
zoom until we can do in-person events
at each level so that we're going to try
and get our candidates to engage with
people
earlier on not just at election time and
start holding like town halls
in every single district so that we're
engaging people
now not waiting until election time and
that people start to feel like they can
give that kind of input
hold q and a's we're also looking at new
texting technology
new uh voicemail technology so we're
looking at a lot of different
ideas to come up with um hybrid
solutions but customizable solutions
adaptable solutions so that we're
constantly looking at ways to get better
um instead of just relying on you know
the past
methodology um in this society
and the way things are moving so fast
all the time and and people
engage differently than they did before
we've got to keep up with that we've got
to keep pace with
those changes uh i think i'm out of
questions
thank you uh unless anything else you
wanted to add i appreciate you setting
up your phone in the bookshelf and the
whole deal
[Laughter]
thank you no we're just very very
committed to
re-electing senator cortes masto and
governor sislak
um we are not going to be the ones that
that give up that senate majority i can
tell you that right now as hard as
as hard as georgians worked we're going
to do that work too just real quick real
quick um
you talk about senator cortez masto and
desire to get her
keep her in office any um
despite the fact that by all accounts
whether it was
senator cortez master so representative
lee others
they weren't necessarily pulling for you
to win
uh does that does that affect you at all
does that bother you at all no
no not at all i mean that's just
internal politics that's the way things
go sometimes
um it doesn't stop me from doing the
work i've got things to focus on i've
got work to focus on
and i've got to expand this democratic
party here in nevada i've got to
re-elect all of our democratic
candidates
and we're starting to map out strategies
for looking at
other districts where we haven't
necessarily had a candidate to run
or we've sort of given ground to
republicans
we're looking at you know school board
races city council races we're looking
at
other ways to expand you know on the
chess board so to speak so
we're going to be looking at all of
those races
and looking at a bottom-up approach as
well
so that we're engaging at a grassroots
level and getting people
actively involved in the party so it
really
it really um doesn't affect the way i do
business and i don't
consider it personal i i know that's the
way things go sometimes it's just
that's the way things go um but it
doesn't
distract me from focusing on what i need
to do and in fact um
you know i've talked with a lot of our
representatives and a lot of our
legislators
and you know i'm going to show them
we're ready to do the work and we're
going to succeed
so it's just that simple all right
good luck to you thank you again for
accommodating the uh the interview in
the zoom and everything i appreciate it
thank you very much take care thank you